Mr Wonderful you know I am right now I'm
in the Carl F buer Boutique in the buer
store it's pretty good right now I'm
with someone very special here a good
friend of mine faren he is the CEO of
one flight faren what does one flight do
so essentially the uh the Expedia of
private jets which is non-existence
we're the only one in the world so we
have access to 6,000 aircraft all over
the globe wherever you want to fly from
we're there for you so you have a a lot
of private clients obviously that really
value their time yes okay you know
people say what do you sell and I don't
want to say we sell private jet service
but I believe we sell time right but
we're in talking about time with watches
right now yes now let's talk about the
history of this project um you called me
up maybe a year and a half ago or so a
year it's been a while okay why did you
ask me so I knew you went to watch us
and I knew I I knew you were the guy to
go to and what I wanted to do was I
wanted to recognize my top top tiered
clients and I thought since we're in the
business of selling time what a great
reward or an award to give to somebody
who I recognize as a top client and I
thought a Time piece so I called you I
said Kevin need some help how do I get a
a Time piece that's so unique that you
can only get it from my hands and really
represent present somebody very special
to the to the company and you connected
me y obviously so let's talk about the
challenge of that the idea of making a
one-of-a-kind piece in a very small run
that would become cherished by the
person who received it a momento of an
incredible relationship but to actually
not only do that to build a dial that
was different than any other dial the
company ever made these were the things
you wanted yes now that is really hard
to do by anybody's standard I don't care
what relationship you have in the watch
industry and I know them all but to
actually do what faren wanted was a
unique Challenge and so I turned at that
time to a relationship I had in New York
with you know turnau because they're a
fantastic dealer Ira the CEO I said Ira
how do I pull this off what brand would
even consider this and this is even
before Booker had acquired turnau and
the booker stores were merged together
and then Rolex spot them both so there's
been a lot of moving around corporately
but he said to me there is one maker in
the world that might be able to pull
this off that would give you the
diversity of optionality that you could
design a dial like the one you
want only
one yes Carl F
Booker
1888 that's how long these guys have
been making watches and we went to them
I talked said could you even think about
doing this and they said we can do it
ichihuahua that's when the journey
started because that's just the
beginning Mr Wonderful here no one needs
a watch but everybody wants one why
because it marks a moment of time in
your life many Watchers appreciate and
value over time that's why I created
Wonder care want to learn more about
ensuring your watch go to ware.com
that's just the beginning how to design
the dial what did you want in features
and functionality of the watch so we
limited it to only 24 it may take me 10
years to identify 24 of my what I call
Medallion members but you're funding
this project from the beginning yes
there's certain identity I wanted to
present in there obviously the colors of
the company the blacks and reds and I
wanted to represent Aviation wait till
see this piece all
right before we see it though we must
get some champagne in here this is a
very special moment buy a watch online
what are you
kidding this is why you don't do that
you get this experience which will never
forget let's do the reveal are you ready
we're going to reveal the
[Music]
Prototype
wow look at
that that's a beautiful time piece let's
go through the basic elements that you
wanted that have been interpreted into
this style so first off the colors of
the company the red and blacks that's
our company it's our brand colors I
wanted that to signify us
secondly it's it's about the aviation
industry right so I wanted to have
somewhere in there you wanted an
aircraft some and and we didn't know
what we wanted we just said we want
Aviation and the idea of the a plane
came about in just our conversations
with you know with the with the store
and they said we'll put a plane in there
we didn't know how that was going to
turn out and when I'm looking at this
that plane is in a constant movement
it's a secondhand and it it doesn't do
the tick tick it's just a constant
movement and that's our brand the bottom
it says o f one flight the top says
Medallion so it's actually recognizing
The Medallion member
so I think those elements were very
important the third element was the
metal and you and I talked about the
metal yeah in reference to what it
should be and we ended up with gold and
then it ended up with white gold I think
that whole representation has turned out
beautiful yeah this is the DNA of why
watches are made to celebrate moments
this is this is what it's all about and
you have become one of the world's most
intriguing collector because not many
companies get to do what you
did I'm happy to have done it with you
yeah I'm I'm I'm very proud I've never
had a project like this in my life I'm
glad of the outcome now the gold pieces
going into production and within a few
months one of 24 will be on this Earth
as well but what a place to actually
reveal this prototype and what a
partnership yeah right fantastic
cheers all right thank you thank
you